lorenzo magnifique bélier de race
mérinos de rambouillet se prépare pour
le salon de l'agriculture
dès samedi et durant neuf jours ce mâle
de 4 ans qui te ra la bergerie nationale
pour représenter les ovins pour faire
honneur à sa race importés d'espagne en
1786 il a eu droit un soin particulier
la traditionnelle taille des ongles en
comprendre séance de manucure et
pédicure et une tonte au mois d'août
afin de présenter une toison de six mois
irréprochable pour l'anecdote lorenzo
qui tient son prénom d'un berger
retraités de la bergerie nationale
produit l'équivalent de 9000 kilomètres
de fibres de laine chaque année le
manteau qu'on lui fait porter depuis
jour de sa tombe ça fait six mois à peu
près
a pour but d'éviter que les impuretés
viennent salir sa toison notamment la
poussière mais aussi toutes les
impuretés végétal le foin la paille
puisque il evian bergerie donc il ya
forcément des impuretés qui pourrait
venir souiller la toison le travail des
bergers s'est aussi porté sur le
comportement de lorenzo le mouton est un
animal grégaire habitué à vivre en
communauté pour parader au salon il a
donc découvert les balades en solitaire
et en laisse les premières sorties en
dehors du groupe pose souvent des
problèmes je l'aï mal et s'inquiète un
peu folle habitués après on ne peut pas
être très familier avec un bédié parce
que il vient très vite très vite assez
cabot à ses débuts avec ses 85 kg
lorenzo a beau porter le prénom d'un
humain il n'en reste pas moins une bête
de caractère